c'est fred et aulas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais alors le voilà on verra vite c'est
le problème même de verre vide hop tout
de suite une vanne vers vide qui ne dit
mot consent
bien alors dans la nouvelle nouvelle
nouvelle nouvelle formule de nulle part
ailleurs
vous intervenez au visiophone un bon
soir à dire qui tu as tu nies beau gosse
son activité moi je voulais parler
d'arielle dombasle et bhl parce que j'ai
lu dans un journal qui se vouvoient fois
encore c'est pas ça le pire
le pire c'est qu'ils couchent ensemble
bonsoir alibaba j'appelle avec un des
voleurs parce qu'elle te donne il a dit
qu'il voulait très incarnée en femme
mais il a bien raison en plus il a de
toute la garde-robe on soient à nos
côtés he man moi je voulais pas aidé
sondage de la presse là comme quoi il ya
de moins en moins de curé en france
enfin en même temps c'est bien voici
surtout les enfants qui vont être
contents bonsoir chapi chapo amis du
matin moi je vous appelle parce que 40
blé sa famille vont divorcer at on dit
c'est normal il a menti tout le temps
il a dit qu'il joue au real de madrid
elle n'a jamais vu jouer c'est pour ça
il évoqué bonsoir prospère je suis aura
du pain d'épicés moi j'appelle à propos
de la disparition de garcimore
franchement ça sert à rien d'être triste
1 pour une fois qu'il réussit à tour
bonsoir mariah carey on vous appelle
parce qu'on a lu dans le journal que
céline dion va s'acheter une maison au
canada
à la vue des attaques sont maintenant à
la maison va fouiller les maintenances
et lui même allaient rentrer chez toi
attendu et consorts ne knicks détective
privé
moi je voulais réagir parce que j'ai vu
que ya des rumeurs sur pascal obispo qui
serait avec fabien barthez
personnellement je sais pas si c'est
vraiment faim en tout cas la bonne
nouvelle est qu'ils pourront jamais
faire de grosses bonsoir simbad mava
j'appelle là puisqu'ils vont faire une
poupée jennifer lopez mais j'espère
qu'ils vont pas lui faire le même qu à
la poupée sinon c'est les mecs qui vont
jouer avec quoi bon soin cette année
charles ben nous voulait réagir sur
christian clavier là parce qu'on a lu
qu'il allait jouer
napoléon taille donne un ego
surdimensionné tout correspondre à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai vachement bien
oui parce merci non non vraiment sartec
cousin vous vous êtes donc tous les
soirs dans nulle part ailleurs
une pareille en vrai canal+ est alors
vous êtes aussi dans grand zapping des
manuels gomme
voilà oui c'est que ça voilà on ferait
des homards savez comment on fait donc
ouais on sait tous les samedis 19h25
jusqu'à 20h45 frais de homard avec
emmanuelle gaume dans plus de zapping
ajoute une balle c'est dur a parlé de ce
soir qui est accessoire dans c'est quoi
l'émission c'est que vous êtes commencer
comment l'ambiance à canal alors
l'ambiance et qu'est ce que c'est que
canal canal une chaîne de télévision
l'esprit canal la grande famille la
grande famille de canal c'est sympa hein
ah oui c'est vrai on s'entend bien on
mange pas de porc pour tous parce que
tout le monde seulement voilà aucun
doigt se lève on mange pas de porc à
canal
alors près de 26 ans fred c'est
incroyable s'est pas dit mon âge quand
je suis arrivé il ya de l'info la tenant
non mais j'ai 26 ans mais à la colle sur
loup
ici tout ça franchement plaisir deug de
droit
ouais j'ai arrêté en lice et ans non
mais ramé écoute moi bien que les stars
puisque christophe je le connais c'est
mon voisin alain christophe qui est
décédé en poussière alors qu'il est là
la fonction non mais c'est ce que permet
un truc machin peu tendu parce que là
vous avez parlé de son bloc de droit et
moi j'ai pas mon bac
alors faut pas le dire un taille haie
alors la fuite la fiche non 2-2 droit
famille bourgeoise
j'aimerais quand même que vous avez
refusé la bourgeoisie 1 par contre c'est
très grave
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] plein de
thunes etc etc
et vogue la galère faut pas que tu me
film toi aussi allez faut pas filmer
parce que je t'aime pas dont je venais à
paris vous venez à paris vous quittez la
colle sur loup vous venez à sa rivale
dans la sema en fait un stage à luchon
mais c'est comme si on regarde la télé
et on se dit comment il trouve là chez
toi là je me dis autant bernard bernard
ça fait trente ans de carrière à tout le
monde le connaît ouais donc c'est normal
qu'on les infos pascal a dit des
conneries n'a pas dit des conneries tu
sais rien bernard on a du doc
ouais c'est vrai moi ouais quoi vous
arrivez à paris fait un stage à fun vous
rencontrer et lesquels anne du sault
chars et voilà j'ai envie d'allumer une
banane
le nouvel an le nouvel an se ralliant ya
de la mana roma roma 23 ans
ouais naître avant attention 23 ans
aujourd'hui
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est parti
m vic surchauffée mais bon public botte
de djamel eddine ha je vois ça alain
azerot comptable botte de djamel enfants
construisent et c'est vrai que cette
pâte avec celles qui vous ont aidé si
jamais la même qu'à ses débuts les
dénoncer aux médisants donner l'adresse
de calleja c'est pas mal non il m'a
accompagné il m'a frappée par la marée
noire et combien je me trompe peut en
parler aussi c'est vrai parce que mon
voisin 87 ans je suis dit tout le moins
par un g10 parce que tout le monde en
parle j'en prends pas moi banier de
cancer 16 j'ai reçu un bon soir ça va
j'ai reçu un e-mail me disant pourquoi
il ya toujours ça la fout de savoir qui
c'est serge serge c'est le réalisateur
nous apprend rien à xambox à canal ouais
si je reconnais c'est loupé magnéto fait
bien
là je m en jingle parce que c'est la fin
de la première partie de l'interview et
là je vous dis mais je savais qu'on ne
bouge pas dans la jungle
ah oui ma
alors là ça fait 40 ans tu fais de la
télé mais personne ne rigole pour tous
c'est l'avantagé dans la région ça
commence et qui réalisa temps oui voilà
en 74 de choc pétrolier
voilà on change de personnes au courant
voilà tu as fini de rire ça fait plaisir
non non ce que je veux dire pourquoi ne
pas obliger pendant le jingle tu me dis
ça à moi non mais celle des semaines que
je joue
pourquoi pourquoi surjouée pourquoi et
c'est parce que parce que voilà pourquoi
pour parce que imaginons par exemple
ravaillac
oui parce que j'ai eu avec 1,9 qui
s'appelle sophie dans la loge ravaillac
et c'est que tu es le roi imagine
travail soit à morne et qui viennent et
que vous mourrez vous mourriez et mouret
et on a touché de la bonne
[Applaudissements]
on ne bouge pas pendant le single en
bouche ma pendant l'été
on ne bouge pas voilà non mais je sais
mais je n'avais pas fini mais je me la
finir maintenant se passe ou sinon mais
je me disais un problème de ravaillac un
ravaillac 2000 par exemple si l'arrivée
et qui vous tue attiré m'en serais bien
dans la merde jamais pourquoi on ne
bouge pas la roma qui a essayé dont
laurent baffie notoriété là on va fier
fait si et de ci de là et c est pourquoi
pour qui et on ne l'a jamais dit pour me
busch et voilà on ne saura jamais
j'emporterai le secret dans ma tombe
comme l'endroit de match parce qu'on n'a
qu'une vie mais moi perso ce soir non en
fait je veux dire la vérité rire il ya
le secret est enfermé dans mon coffre à
la banque dans une enveloppe scellée
qu'on ouvrira à ma mort
alors il fallait que tu meurs en même
temps c'est pour rigoler avec le public
numérique alors des vannes criantes
aussi bien pour moi c'est non mais qui
m'a énervé que vos parents sont blancs
et que les votes sont noirs
et ça vous fait rigoler baisser la
tension en charge
ah oui il faut dire quand il lui faut
dire non à ces l'interview mensonge
c'est à dire le contraire de la vérité
oui ouais et vous ils sont noirs bah
c'est évident c'est ridicule est il un
vrai que lorsque alain de greef vous a
vu pour la première fois elle nous a pas
reconnus qui nous a pas reconnus côté
vous avez vu pour la première fois mais
c'est normal
enfin c'est pas normal par contre à vous
avez exigé quoi dans votre contrat avec
canal+ nous ce qu'on exigeait ans parce
que on s'en occupe pas en fait un temps
où le mensonge de votre bureau vous avez
quoi à cannes à la tectonique des
plaques c'est à dire c'est la faille de
san andreas est intéressant parce que la
tectonique des plaques on n'en parle pas
assez et ça se frotte comme ça et à la
faille passe par canal exactement tous
les scores les vacances vous les prenez
au mensonge sous ou pas ah ouais ah
c'est mon souhait parce que moi je reste
chez moi
le calcul fait quelques qu'est ce qu'il
vous faut bon ce soir à du vin espagnol
les nouveaux conquérants de l'europe
formidable
oui alors les vins espagnols et il y en
a encore qui sont encore à l'âge de don
quichotte mais par contre il y en ad
extra tiens je vous faire goûter quelque
chose de voir la côte et moi ça ouais ça
c'est la ribera del duero magnifique
il fait tourner le vin rouge mais fait
comme moi on veut que tu donnais grosse
gorgée n'auront pas trop ça c'est assez
souple un nombre assez souple un poids
trop puissant ça ressemble à calvin
français ça conforte olivades qu'olive
plus quoi ça se vend dans le monde
entier savent hop et russe avotvaz
langevin savons tous à quel sur lui
acheter ça
156 100 euros les billysiens c'est moins
cher aux euro euro euro euro annoncée
moins cher nous tue entre 15 et je veux
sentir quand même
ah bah oui ça tu peux sentir la bière
ont cette fois nettement ses fruits
noirs et ses fruits noirs une maman mais
[Musique]
maintenant je peux pas la loi
vraiment je passais mes nom puisqu'elle
ramadan bien tout ça veut dire car
justement on profite des abruzzes mais
tu as droit de recracher pour cracher
vous garder que les arômes et saveurs et
d'arômes l'ain alors vous en voulez
combien pas une bouteille pour elles
tendent aimerait pas en commun avant ou
bien en personne ah bon pourquoi pas
tant le rouleau
comme dit mes collaborateurs une palette
non j'ai pas de l'outaouais d'accord
deux ça fait mouche en entier dont les
mecs vous devez vous faire un max de
thune m'a quand même mois à peu près
dans les vingt mille baladeuses sait pas
faire des conneries ah ouais d'argent
mais mon marabout me l'avait dit au jdd
qu est d'en faire un nom ben moi j'ai
une smart tu vois je redis pour être le
pays et bien donné je ne paierai les
adore et toi j'ai une voiture
extraordinaire c'est quoi une ferrari
paraît encore défait la canada parce
qu'ils sont partis avec les indemnités
vous puissiez plus le mode la mode les
faire il entend les murs et les smart et
avec les avec les gonzesses ça non mais
moi je suis bien avec bertrand qui sait
peut-être pas là pour en parler je sais
on va voir tout de suite j'espère rester
là et ici avec messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien ça fait peur d'un coup ses fils
alors on va commencer par toi oui tu vas
faire comme si tu l'a rencontrée dans
une boîte de nuit un soir qu'est ce que
tu lui dirai pour la draguer bonsoir une
je vous ai vu un jour
chardy annonce à ses parents
excusez moi mais bon qu'est ce tu
connais toi fred si tu rencontres est
ici un soir dans une boîte de nuit
je t'aime pardon c'est se donner un
double râteau oui c'est ça c'est merci
les filles de vote
[Musique]
ça remet en thaïlande et dans les villas
gens l'écoutent
ah oui alors lequel des ajustements
interview dernier coup
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas pendant les jean galle
il a fait un repère on rallume
on refait pourtant je la regarde et me
seban ouais je sais mais bon on va faire
une interview dernier coup on a vu
pendant les dégâts
[Applaudissements]
très bien as tu peux bouger la whey
dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur tourcoing ouais ouais j'aime bien
cette ville moi c'est jean pascal
je trouve que c'est un garçon qui a
plein de talent et d'émotion
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup de poing dans les coups de
poing j'ai vu chez qui le nul mais ta
coupe point un mec là pendant un match
ouais j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire mois
à bouli dans les loges à m'énerver que
son casque l'année coup de folie un
aspirateur 1500 arrêté a été vraiment de
la tude ainsi peut-être des filtres à
café que j'étais bien j'ai claqué au
moins dans les sandales 200 peut-être en
euros ouais ça fait ça à peu près
[Rires]
dernier coup de foudre
je postule moment pour mais j'avais été
chercher mon courrier chez moi et en
fait dans la cage d'escalier donc je
descends et j'ai croisé ma mère et on
sait se regarder tout ça tu vois voilà
j'ai un peu craqué ça s'est arrangé avec
ta mère tu vois la coke dans les coups
de gueule enfin et coups de gueule b à
l'aspirateur
après je fais engueuler quand le dernier
coup de pub mais c'était avant
d'aspirateur ah non moi c'est quand j'ai
dit omar tiens regarde la bague et une
crêpe au fromage que tu appelles
[Rires]
j'avais tout fils j'ai appelé le mec
pour qu'il fasse marcher l'aspirateur
d'acteurs plus non moi c'est j'ai appelé
mon père pour lui expliquer par un
dernier coup de roue je te demande pas
tu vois pas toi non non jamais jamais ah
non moi je trouve que sans alcool la
fête est plus folle tiens c'est ma
devise
ouais c'est bien dernier coup de soleil
c'est pas marrant
[Applaudissements]
et en plus c'est vraiment toi moi c'est
quand je me lève le matin que je tourne
la tête et c'est ce qu'il évoquait ce
qui les musées français aller bronzer
dernier coup de bol est un petit bijou
des bois du risque dernier coup de pouce
tony coup de blues baisse et là
maintenant parce que je sais qu'on n'ira
jamais chez fogiel quoi dernier cobra
d'un coup droit il ya deux ans j'ai
donné un rein mec
tony n'a pas de jambes en berne des
grisons et de l'autre nous on prépare
notre âme adorno battu ses records nous
c'est la garenne au pouce et karen
notamment j'ai pas de boeuf séchée ou la
viande des grisons
non merci je comprends pas nous mange
bien des coûts et d'image
alors pourquoi un état grave nous c'est
vous les récits brésil 8 à 6 à la fin
c'est un devenir un as dans un jeu peut
pas ses traders y est c'est grave
hamelin a bah ouais il fait chaud plus
là bas j'avais un enfer bon si on mange
du porc ouais c'est un enfer
enfin bon ça aussi ouais comme nous vous
le vert paradis les mieux soit
paradisiaque en biais des vierges et du
miel
tu vois ça c'est pour les martyrs roty
ii sobra savannah on a fait c'est la
botte de chorizo cabillaud ah merde
piqué au showbiz de léonard va manger
chez toi c'est pas la peine on a fait un
échange sur les jours si l'on tisse
assez classique la sacem brice tu me
rendre au bristol il ya que des émirs du
moyen-orient maintenant les palaces à
paris c'est tout de même dans ta chambre
égorger tomber tous les mecs allemand et
respecte ça se passe bien on a repris
canal dès cette année et puis le
spectacle dont le dans le grand journal
chef non cédant samedi pétanque
ah oui d'accord auquel vous faites comme
zéro fait une sorte de modules le
visiophone non mais en mieux on a de la
chance chez spectacle franchement on a
de la chance a bien démarré sur courage
ans donc voilà maintenant je pense qu'on
est parti pour dix ans et fille sont
aussi il ya une séparation marketing à
faire peut-être ça peut être intéressant
ça c'était un moment vers l'un s'appelle
amour parce que la commune et des zones
où ils se remettent ensemble serait même
quand on se sépare je les ai vus
ensemble à la baisse bah moi je suis
casé sympa sans fin
moi ça fait un moment toujours la même
j'ai deux enfants j'attends le troisième
et le retard même déjà 27 27 ans déjà
trois ans de retard
je suis un père de six enfants
toi non pas deux ben moi je serai là
chez nous tu sais les catholiques
j'accueille maintenant omar et fred
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au maghreb ont 60 ans pas ce soir donc
omar et fred vous êtes toujours sur
canal +
pas de changement tout va bien non tout
va bien bien parce qu'il faut dire à nos
amis téléspectateurs et arnaud
montebourg qui était très occupé ces
derniers temps pas d'actualité politique
après le 11 septembre et avant le 21
avril
l'autre grand bram de ces derniers mois
c'est le limogeage de pierre lescure qui
a été zappé de la direction de canal+
par jean marie messier ce qui a donné
lieu à une mutinerie mutinerie de 24
heures à peu près vous avez fait quoi
durant la mutinerie vaut sans manger des
bounties nous n'était présent sur le
front la ligne maginot charles de gaulle
étoile
ouais ça vous protestez notre haine on a
fait les manifs en effet votre 1068 vrai
comme on avait arrêté l'école plutôt ça
nous a permis de refaire des manifs on a
séché le travail
alors est ce que vous êtes rassurés à
canal+ par l'effacement de xavier
couture au profit de dominique farrugia
oui oui mieux rigole
ouais ça reste là je l'aï envoyé des
photos couture va s'occuper de
l'étranger la pologne la finlande est
infâme surtout beaucoup mais c'est du
boulot alors et lescure on dit qu'il va
faire la météo dans l'émission de
frédéric beigbeder à la rentrée vous y
croyez il est capable de tout et des
années qui fait la pluie et le beau
temps vous savez quoi alors messi lui il
a un problème parce qu'il avait promis
des stock options aux dirigeants
américains de l'univers soul il est allé
voir ses actionnaires ses actionnaires
lui ont dit bah non donc là quand il va
retourner aux états unis il se faire
casser les pouces nunnari refuser un
essai il vaut mieux
bien et vous vous rêvez comme en jeu
comme la whey bien voilà c'est bien déjà
bien
laurent vous vous rêvez comment on bat
moi en ce moment j'ai tellement de trucs
tout va bien on doit pas faire mieux et
tout ce trésor
vous rêvez comment réélu dans un mois ce
genre de geste un non non non alors dans
la bresse il ça fonctionne dans la
braise est très bien mais arnova de
changer cela commençait presque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
en faire une nouvelle interview avec
bull ça s'appelle quand je taperai dans
mes mains tu sors
on ne bouge pas pendant le génial voilà
voilà où en est la france on bouge
pendant le single voilà il est temps que
sarkozy mette un peu d'ordre à tout ça à
mon ami avec devedjian
ouais omar quand je te ferai dans mes
mains tu seras bien lescure je mange
[Applaudissements]
quand je taperai dans mes mains tu seras
xavier couture hockey atome à rouyn
besoin d'augmentations une famille
nombreuse à nourrir et ça va être
effective dans les prochains jours
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour vous omar quand je taperai
dans les mains tu sauras jean marie le
pen le soir du premier tour
non me ferais du fémur coin ne peut le
faire il fait le passé mission vous êtes
un homme malsain technocrates vous
pressez pas la france métal ou acculé de
dettes surendettés
[Applaudissements]
hélas
mardi
bien quand je taperai dans les mains tu
seras michael jackson et vingt gamins de
présentoirs des fins humanitaires nos
matches mais qu'est ce qu'elle a ma très
bien avec la cravate c'est quand je
serai prêt dans les mains tu seras
monsieur riche en beaux de tours il est
décédé ce matin c'est pas bien de se
moquer dément je vais pas faire ma
chambre
elle doit être un peu triste mais nous
mari meurt ce matin le président tient
au mas quand après dans les mains tu
feras benjamin castaldi civile et que
félicien se bat à mains nues contre un
grizzly tapez 1
par contre si vous voulez que les céni
se fasse prendre par le gaz unis
c'est ça
j'étais à prêt dans le match sera dieu
faire la dune c'est vrai oui trop de
croyance non non pas de trucs sur dieu
lui a le il a même jour à ses limites
il a peur de dieu oui tu sais faire le
diable les météos
[Applaudissements]
attention quand je taperai dans le
marbre
tu seras fred l'inité lieu au mas non
c'est à vous la tension quand je taperai
dans mes mains vous serez thierry
ardisson mois le nouveau thierry
ardisson le pote de guy bedos
j'accueille mon ami de toujours guy
bedos
je reçois matin armé d'un omar et fred
et vincent desagnat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
cassez vous cassez
[Applaudissements]
chansons n'ont finalement j'ai aucune
envie de les voir pavot et ce qui s'est
passé audience j'accueille map
maintenant commence pas parce que là je
vais le faire dix fois ci quand on veut
peut-être comédiens on articule il a
joué deux pour moi il est comédien bien
j'accueille mince tant armelle deutsch
omar et fred et vincent desagnat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et la tradition très bien alors tout le
monde attend c'est de notre déménagement
faire dedans bon tu as ramené au plus
tard l empire attendez vous dire que
c'est bien showest awards et aux queues
c'est gentil c'est très gentil tu pars
le coeur
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans notre dont
j'aime bien ça il ya une petite poupée
vaudou pour toi ouais vous savez que
vous savez de la poupée bien sûr il ya
un string mangeable a très bien merci
présent il ya ça je sais quoi
excuse moi c'est pas du papier à rouler
way [ __ ] ils sont pas venus les mains
vides la noria les clips bagnoles 2
laurent ruquier il ya d'autres trucs art
là où il ya ça ah ouais ça je peux les
genres et déjà celle là je les aimais
bons jeux d'affilée alors c'est tout
dans ce carton non mais je crois que
j'ai eu je crois que j'ai un autre à
penser à un truc que j'ai retrouvé
derrière une dune étagères autre chose
qu'on peut m'amener l'autre car tôt pour
thierry
[Musique]
oui
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
pour la forme elle obligée de partir
alors j'ai voulu
votre film bottes film c'est le meilleur
film des plus grands films que j'ai
jamais vu le carton d'accord et on va
commencer par armelle parce qu'on se
connaît pas non mais ne donne rien à
voir avec lorànt deutsch et mama c'est
son fils vous serez décès mon prix vous
avez décidé de faire du théâtre à l'âge
de 12 ans d'abord vous rentrez dans une
troupe adolescente à marseille c'est ta
vie que je raconte cyril à monter à
paris cours florent pas facile beaucoup
de courage la vocation chevillée au
corps vous trouvez un agent wii qui est
une seconde maman pour vous convaincre
que la première heureusement d'ailleurs
la première étape c'est ta vie que je
raconte
et puis là c'est parti un jour tu te
retrouves devant les caméras de patrick
sabatier en train de faire mariner sera
dure et chaque minute en plus clair t'as
essayé toupie finalement tu l'as pas
fait tu trouvé ça ridicule de faire mal
aux rochers sabatier mon avis tu avais
raison
ensuite on te voit dans le placard ou
tuer la secrétaire de michèle laroque
c'est là que depardieu sur le tournage
je te mets une main au cul mais tu te
défend très bien très très bien tu
remets les choses tout de suite au clair
et après tu as parlé comme il faut voilà
ensuite la boîte de zidi et là tu
t'aperçois finalement les réalisateurs
sont pas tous les mêmes parce que j'y
dis finalement n'attache pas une énorme
importance au dialogue est pour toi les
dialogues c'est pas un détail
ensuite tu fais laisse mes mains sur tes
hanches le chantal lauby nos amis les
flics de bob swaim imola nombreux enfin
ce que je voulais dire sable on sait que
tu la nouvelle fille drôle et sexy du
cinéma français pourquoi pas bah oui non
mais c'est sûr et j'espère que c'est un
bon positionnement puis on a passé un
contenu c'est bien c'est bien vincent
desagnat bonjour bonsoir donc ex de la
bande à michaël youn
oui c'est pas fini mais explorer pour
pour ce projet à ses côtés dans la beuze
dans les 11 commandements et dans les
bratisla boys
[Musique]
omar et fred bonsoir bonsoir donc
d'abord canal arte canal+ vous avez
fréquenté et gassion j'imagine canada
l'an
quel talent grand bonhomme et grands
penseurs maintenant il fait des livres
avec bilger et voilà on sait pas c'est
facile je les écoute penser alors
aujourd'hui un one man show qui reprend
le 12 octobre théâtre chaude a way où
s'échouent c'est dans le one man show il
fait nommer il fait chaud c'est le début
du one man ça non c'est un autre truc
sauce qui fait chômage et toi tu as la
version vous êtes tous ici pour un film
qui s'appelle le voilà un film de
charles nemes la comédie qui déménage
puisque c'est l'histoire d'un mec pas de
vous elle a raconté qui va raconter le
pitch des armes elles arrivent à l'école
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui doit
déménager demain sauf que demain c'est
aujourd'hui
et voilà et donc évidemment il a plein
dans merde et à tous qu'il est bâti de
problèmes mais on va voir à quoi ça
ressemble c'est ce que vous allez faire
tous les quatre vers ghardaïa autre
caméra c'est le cal rouge et vous allez
dire magnéto serge comme andy garcia à
2,3 à 3 2 3 je suis dans la merde mais
je déménage conscientise est une menace
est aujourd'hui qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui à tous dans la merde
giraudier sa fille un trésor dans les
têtes et dieu c'est le cas partout bah
oui je perds tout l'argent la caution
rien tout à lorenzo massa fait pour la
camionnette et un pinceau des cartons
des cartons c'est pour des vivres
j'ai commencé avec des sacs étant à des
cartons voilà un marine et garonne frère
voilà mais vous allez boire des bières
là comme ça un gros déménagement ça se
passe toujours avec des bières c'est les
bases c'est lorenzo j'ai bien eu ton
message pour la camionnette celui qui
fait chier toute la rue là tu vas
minutes
on sait pas lui mr jobs espèce de
bouffon on attend la voiture à venir ici
faire des photos avec un mannequin c'est
très tendance et appart vide comme c'est
pour ça que je demande si c'est clean
chez antoine bien sûr que c'est clean à
temps il ya la coi pour cinq minutes on
va ranger passif est comme chez toi ma
poule
norton 9e en moyenne je sèche au courant
sanguin de me dire c'est la polonaise
qui vient faire cette photo bonjour je
suis la fille du propriétaire est les
patrons français de la casse cou
j'espère que ce qui s'est passé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà le carton le charme et mai
avec tous les gens qui sont là plaisir
et djamel bouras et aimer les chaînés
catherine benguigui cécilia cara au
début c'était une pièce de théâtre un
carton car elle sent tranquille
spéculateurs c'est bien alors la suite
est à l'étude
il va y avoir bientôt le carton 2,4
directement directeur avec stallone
voilà les gars dont vous n'échapperez
pas aux questions qui tuent vincent ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu le cul
de michael youn comment il va pas mal de
travaux seront nécessaires
ça vous embête pas vincent que le qi de
michaël youn soit plus connue que votre
tête
north of s'interroge pas du tout ça te
fait rire mais vous n'avez pas peur
vincent qu'un jour un mec arrive et vous
disons vous tapant sur l'épaule comme ça
ça va les conneries maintenant foire
était fort en de l'argent mais ça m'est
arrivé hier soir à ouais bon voilà non
ça ne dérange pas armelle quitte à
prendre le nom d'un acteur déjà connu
pourquoi pas gabin et ventura pourquoi
j'ai beaucoup hésité
c'est ça le problème c'est que mon père
s'appelait deutsch décevoir non ouais et
vous n'avez pas peur que en vous
appelant donne le film l'américain
nuisent à votre carrière
je pense que ça va légèrement le
compromettre mais j'invite tous les gens
à y aller quand même quand même comment
omar et fred
c'est comme la dernière fois c'est à
dire toi tu es le noir c'est toujours
maria paz d'omar pour le cinéma vous
savez qu'un français sur deux n'est même
pas les noirs chez vous c'est lequel
c'est lui d'accord ça s'est passé
naturellement vous avez vraiment choisi
d'être leblanc dans le dans le duo non
début j'étais l'homosexuel à dakar puis
finalement je suis devenu le blanc roule
bidon pourquoi bruno salomone ne fait
pas la promo avec vous vous allez à la
soirée avant première une soirée pour
dire se goinfrer de quiche lorraine
son but karim ziani
ils sont tous égaux
ça fait dur
jean-vincent mais je vous laisser filer
parce que parce que vous êtes ensemble
qu'on peut le dire c'est ça oui mais on
a cassé hier et on a repris enfin bon
c'est en tentant parce que moi j'étais
avec le producteur avant donc oui mais
pas mic mac tu te souviens tu es voilà
c'est ça dont plusieurs dans tes bras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 j'avais demandé à mes lignes de
m'amener un truc spécial pour vous et
alors que c'est bien sûr que je laime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
moi c'est mon meilleur jour
et oui allait bien aller la wii allait
bien ça on reste allait bien aussi elle
est vraiment bien j'ai même pas tu vois
il ya un invité qui doit venir après
j'aime et j'ai même pas envie d'inviter
pourtant c'est le patron de vanity fair
je devrais le l'invité mais bon je vais
alors les gars les plus sûrs ils
renseignent chez pas moi j'essaie de
partir alors maintenant on va passer un
genre que vous connaissez bien puisque
on vient de le voir pour hisser le
répondeur intervient répondeur
[Musique]
vous allez me laisser des messages
bonjour j'ai bien sûr portable de
laurent ruquier si vous avez un jeu de
mots laissez moi un message bip monsieur
madame tendo dans le placard parce que
tu as tu rejoues et ont une fille
comment s'appelle cette fille mélanie
pourquoi et la nintendo dans le placard
parce que tu as trop chou et ouais
bonjour vous êtes bien sur le portable
de jamel debbouze si c'est pas pour me
demander de la thune laissez moi un
message bip
oui bonjour jamais les spas voulez vous
dire que je vous ai vu dernièrement et
j'ai envie de rejoindre votre collectif
devoir de mémoire
moi aussi j'ai changé je pense qu'il
faut régulariser méchante inspiré lionel
avec moi j'ai changé bonjour j'ai bien
sûr portable de michel sardou si vous
aussi vous êtes pour laissez moi un
message mais pour on serait pour nous
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
oui il devrait faire une chanson là
dessus plutôt d'accord bonjour vous êtes
bien sur le portable de claude berri si
vous voulez pitch est un film laissez
moi un message bip
mais je pense qu'il n'appellera pas
bonjour vous êtes bien son portable de
jacques et bernadette chirac
si vous avez des pièces jaunes mais
c'est moi un message beef bonjour
jacques chirac c'est gérald un amer dans
l'intimité zidane la masure à gauche
bonjour vous êtes bien sur le portable
de nicolas sarkozy si c'est pour revenir
à la maison laissez nous un message
ouais nicolas nous conte la salle owens
et professeur ousmane donc là j'ai fait
revenir les traits mais alors qu'il faut
faire revenir mon appart classique
bonjour j'ai bien son portable de
florent pagny si c'est pour un conseil
fiscal laissez-moi message bip
oui bonjour ce laurent c'est johnny
hallyday dit donc au lieu d'aller en
patagonie tu aurais dû aller en belgique
c'est plus près bonjour j'ai bien son
portable de gérard depardieu je suis
bourré c'est moi un message bip
oui à lou hockey géreur c'est gérald et
en mer de nouvelle a ajouté christian
bonjour j'ai bien sûr portable de
dieudonné
si c'est pour la vérité si je mens 3
laissez moi un message mais à mon avis
il faut parler encoder parce qu'on est
sur écoute
hugo louis dionne dont là on est donc
voila tout pour te dire que le loup est
dans la bergerie
bonjour je viens son portable de george
bush je sais c'est incroyable mais
laissez moi un message bien oui c'est
incroyable parce que je t'appelle de
matons c'est martin luther king j'ai
grandi avec moi et quand tu vas venir
dans l'au-delà nous on a arrêté les
actions non violentes
on va défoncer la gueule bonjour vous
êtes bien sur le portable de omar et
fred dans les chairs 10 ans laissez nous
un message bip
oui ils vont jouer je vous appelle pour
savoir où on peut réserver des places
pour les vélos spectacle on n'a pas
donné l'adresse ni les points de vente
habituels me semble parce que ma cousine
m'a dit que c'était à la grande comédie
rue de clichy
à quelles heures à 20 heures démare dieu
samedi oui je crois
[Musique]
en tournée et le savez les
mission g sur canal
samedi les gens et les
[Musique]
deux toits à coeur
je
ces huit chanceux mais c'est tout les
mêmes ou à chaque fois question non
n'aurait pas photo on la dit vous devez
laisser les chez votre coude et pourquoi
c'est que moi beaucoup de moi assez dure
c'est à dire aller chez son coût de ces
super de mls mais j'aime beaucoup de
chaleur regarde regarde bien
car et c'est bien on voit tes seins
quand tu fais ça bien voilà
chantal lauby oui voilà tout
[Musique]
m
j'ai dit c'est qu'il est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu